valve perab banded this streamer in the
literal funniest way possible this is
Mason former DOTA Pro and current
streamer one day on stream Mason was
opening up his gift for the game's
holiday event and what did I get what I
got banned the dude got banned until
2038 so during the frost ofis event
valve stated that depending on your
behavior score you can get a nice cozy
present if you've been nice or a toxic
piece of coal if you've been naughty are
they serious Mason made and then deleted
a Reddit post explaining his position
admitting to using a behavior booster
for one day but otherwise really didn't
get the ban I don't think I should be
per banned but I think I should be
punished other players called
and said if you can't do the time don't
do the crime I would not play DotA for a
month I think I should be banned and
after mulling it over playing a variety
of games Mason came back made another
account and started his Redemption Arc
go man just go I'm L time